this is Dimitri rolv and he's a
billionaire from Russia Dimitri made
some good Investments and he sold his
two fertilizer companies for a huge
chunk of money which eventually turned
into an 11.4 billion fortune and he's
only getting richer in 2023 alone he
increased his net worth by over a
billion dollar but right now like all of
Russia's billionaires the Mitri has a
big problem sanctions the West started
cracking down after Putin invaded
Ukraine but they aren't just trying to
choke out the government Western
countries have fit over aund of Russia's
richest people with sanctions and froze
their assets
on top of that Putin is also now telling
his billionaires to quote put patriotism
before profit end quote so naturally the
richest people in Russia are getting
very nervous and the Russian
billionaires who managed to narrowly
escape the sanctions like Demitri well
they are not going to sit around and
risk losing everything but luckily he
has an escape see while every other
country is shutting people like him away
there's one place that is welcoming
billionaires like him with open arms
[Music]
Dubai
see Dubai is the perfect escape from the
world's
0.001% all you have to do to get a Visa
in the United Arab Emirates is to invest
at least half a million dollars in real
estates which is pretty much Chum change
to someone like Dimitri who is worth
22,000 times that amount so he did what
any sensible billionaire would do and
invested his money into a $29 million
property over there it was a one-way
ticket to growing and protecting his
wealth even more and he is far from the
only one that made the move to Dubai
tons of other Russian billionaires have
done the same thing businessman Albert
abdan owns two properties in Dubai worth
$19 million and Pavo durov the founder
of telegram has been living in Dubai for
years now but it's not just Rich
Russians who are escaping to Dubai
either billionaires from all around the
world have been low-key planting their
flag in Dubai in fact there are so many
rich people moving to Dubai right now
that there simply isn't enough Supply to
meet the luxury demand in the city
they're literally running out of space
as one Dubai real estate Tycoon put it
quote Dubai is a very small town we had
about 5,000 millionaires move in even if
the market crashes and only 2,500
millionaires move in this year we don't
have enough space or enough homes for
these people and it doesn't look like
this is going to slow down anytime soon
but why why are the rich flocking to
Dubai stay dangerous subscribe for more
and let's get into
[Music]
it rich people always have personal
chefs to save them time but professional
chefs cost a lot of money but thankfully
that is where cook Unity comes in cook
Unity is the best meal Subscription
Service I have ever tried instead of
cheap tasting meals that taste all
manufactured like a lot of other
companies out there cook Unity connects
award-winning chefs with consumers so
that you get fine dining quality meals
right to your doorstep and I was really
Amazed by their selection I tried this
duck conf Fe by Chef Dustin Taylor they
have instructions to heat it up in the
oven or the microwave I went with the
oven and although my planting was not
the best I was shocked it really did
taste like a dish you would get at a
nice restaurant the same goes for Chef
Brandon kaida of Los Angeles with this
grass-fed riby that I made extra eggs
for for super tender well seasoned I
thoroughly enjoy this meal their weekly
menu accommodates numerous diets and
preferences including gluten-free dairy
free keto paleo and vegan options and
the crazy part is that these meals are
actually shockingly affordable you can
pause your subscription skip weeks or
cancel at any time so if you're looking
to save time on cooking where you're not
willing to settle for lowquality food
you got to go to cook unity.com jr50 or
click the link below and use my code J
tr50 to get 50% off your first order of
cookie un click the link below
now
in the past couple decades Dubai went
from a small fishing Village on the edge
of the desert to one of the most iconic
cities in the world seriously Dubai 50
years ago is completely unrecognizable
from the fancy Metropolis everyone knows
today this was the dear neighborhood of
Dubai just a little while ago and this
is what that same area looks like today
all in around 50 years and this
transformation was not by
[Music]
accident
it was all part of the grand plan of a
guy named shik Rashid shik Rashid is a
big reason why the United Arab Emirates
even exist today because he was a
co-founder of the agreement that founded
the country back in 1971 shiki's family
gained promise for turning the city of
Dubai into a local commercial hub back
in the 1930s and ruling over the area he
continued on with that Legacy during his
Reign but he was the one that took it to
a whole another level after a major oil
Reserve was discovered under Dubai
shikashi knew that this place had the
potential to be come the next big thing
the real big differences started when
oil production was increasing and 71 the
companies both onshore and offshore were
producing quite a lot of oil and the
money the revenue from this was
spreading around he wanted to put Dubai
on the map internationally alongside the
likes of New York London Paris or Tokyo
and at the time the idea sounded
completely insane because with these
other cities like New York it took these
places hundreds and hundreds of years to
achieve their worldly esteem on top of
the Middle East at the time wasn't
exactly the first place on Wester mind
when they thought of a vacation spots
but shik Rashid was determined he
started investing in the city's
infrastructure big time with the goal of
modernizing everything he built an
international airport to attract
visitors from across the globe it is
equally evident in the development of
Dubai International which has evolved
from a small airst strip serving a few
Airlines to a global gateway for 130
airlines that is ranked among the
world's top airports but perhaps the
most important thing he did was that he
made Dubai a little bit more moderate a
little bit more Western visit Dubai
today and it definitely feels like an
Islamic country but an Islamic country
with just enough westernization to make
westerners feel comfortable and he
succeeded Beyond his Wildest Dreams in
just a couple years people went from
getting around Dubai on the backs of
camels to riding around the city's
highways in sports cars and today Dubai
is one of the top destinations on the
planet the once Barren land is now H to
things like the tallest building in the
world the largest man-made Island vience
ever and much more it was a complete 180
all of a sudden everyone who was anyone
wanted to be in Dubai it kind of became
the Las Vegas of the Middle East I took
my assistant to Armenia and I went
through Dubai and then I heard that you
were in Dubai not too long ago right I
was there for a very short period of
time but it does feel like you're on
another planet yeah Dubai is I mean it's
basically like Vegas un crack with none
of the subtlety really I it was really
overwhelming it's impressive it's very
impressive place except obviously
there's no gambling it's extremely safe
and it caters to a much wealthier
clientele today Dubai has turned itself
into one of the most appealing places on
the earth for the ultra wealthy because
the truth is that life as a billionaire
in places like the United Kingdom China
and Russia can be real tough that ultra
wealthy there know that at any moment a
judge can just sign a piece of paper
take away all your stuff and throw you
in prison you're paying 50% tax you're
getting restricted more and more you
need to pay taxes when you're a citizen
doesn't matter where you live around the
world how can you call that capitalism
when the government takes half of what
you make so that is the first great
thing about Dubai the country wants you
to create wealth they want you to keep
your wealth in Dubai the government
takes nothing they don't care you can do
anything you want open your business
hire as many people as you want open an
office wherever you want no permits
needed for most things in the US you
want to launch a new business you need
permits all over the place in Dubai it's
just one specific agency where you need
one permit one license and then you open
the business and you start making
millions of dollars and that is what
people are attracted to and secondly as
a billionaire you simply get to a point
where you run out of things to buy but
in Dubai there are plenty of toys to
spend your money
[Music]
on welcome to First Motors in Dubai this
is the world's most extreme car
dealership based on the world famous and
expensive artificial island of palm jera
in Dubai is the luxury hotel resort
Atlantis the palm and it's worth over a
billion dollar building a 20 billion
Mall can result in a pretty impressive
shopping experience including an indoor
Village and one of the world's best
aquariums malls are pretty convenient
all around the world but there's no way
they're as interesting as the Dubai Mall
which features everything from
go-karting and a VR Lounge to real
dinosaur bones with over 1200 stores and
120 restaurants and cafes the Dubai Mall
is the second largest on the planet
Dubai is nicknamed the City of Gold for
a reason do you want to take a brand new
Ferrari and drive it in the middle of
the desert to pretend you're the star of
your own action movie you can feel like
dropping a few $100,000 on the highest
end Brands you can as well want to eat
on an underwater Mission Star Restaurant
and stay at hotels that will service
your every request not a problem don't
want to get stuck in traffic no worries
Dubai is in the process of launching a
city-wide helicopter taxi service very
very soon then you have ATMs that
dispense gold bars and much much more in
2010 a German company by the name X
oriente Lux installed the very first
gold to go machine in the five-star
Emirates Palace Hotel the machine sells
24 karat gold bars weighing 1 5 and 10 G
it also sells gold coins from Canada
Australia and South Africa and as an
added bonus they come in a Sleek
decorative gift box essentially it's a
Cash for Gold without any of that pesky
human interaction to deal with so for
the millionaire or billionaire that's
born and needs an eagle boost Dubai has
everything you could ask for to move on
the next thing I have on my list here is
and one thing I I really appreciate
about Dubai is that it's easy to Cate
your own reality and what I mean by that
is Dubai is literally a place where you
can live whatever life you really want
like you want to rent a villa for
$100,000 a month you can easily do that
you just go on propertyfinder.ae and
find the most expensive Villa on the
palm and that will easily set you back
100K per month or more but you also want
to live like a more normal life maybe
you have a normal job and you want to
try and save up some money and just pay
one grand for an apartment and actually
a nice studio apartment you can also do
that so you can live a super super
extravagant life and you can also live a
super normal life and that exposure to
different scenarios is one thing I
really do appreciate about du buy now
the C out to that and sort of the con is
that you can also easily get sucked into
this spending problem really where Dubai
will just suck out all your money
because there's so much stuff to do like
there's so many Michelin restaurants
like five star restaurants you can go
jet skiing you can go to the desert you
want to go to Bush Khalifa you want to
go to Bush Al Arab to Sal and spend you
know5 $10,000 on a lunch you can also do
that so if you're not very careful you
can easily get into money problems
because there's so much stuff to do and
if you don't have a little bit of
discipline with your money it's very
very easy to get sucked into this
experien economy that Dubai really is
and they're still coming up with new
stuff to woo tourists and the Wolfie all
the time just a couple years ago Dubai
broke the world record for having the
deepest swimming pool ever at 200 ft
deep to give visitors a one-of-a-kind
simulated diving experience it's
mindboggling they have the world's Lar
they have the world's largest indoor
everything everything yeah uh they they
literally do you can go skiing indoors
there you can like on a mountain that
they've built IND inside yeah it's
basically akin to building an indoor
beach in Antarctica like it makes zero
sense that why it would be there but
it's there and also like um you can go
scuba diving in the mall like literally
scuba diving uh you you can do anything
there pretty much so with all these
enticing things and all these Financial
incentives Dubai now has thousands of
millionaires hundreds of Cil
Millionaires and 13 different
billionaires already living in the city
that we know of and more of them are
flooding into the city every single day
some of them are legitimate but some of
them
[Music]
aren't on one hand Dubai is known as
this opulent Paradise but on the other
hand it's also become known as a moneya
laundering Paradise Dubai is a close
Ally of our cont its real estate market
has reportedly become a Haven for money
laundering think about it you've made
your money in a sketchy way and now you
need to wash it so nobody knows where
that money came from but if you try to
spend a bunch of Cold Hard Cash on fancy
cars or real estate in America or the UK
you're going to get question put on the
list you're going to get hunted down but
in Dubai you won't have that problem at
all in fact it's quite the opposite in
Dubai they won't ask you any questions
they won't bog you down with endless
paperwork to make sure your money is
legit all that matters is if you have
the cash if you do the property is yours
and just like that you can easily turn
millions of illegitimate dollars into a
very legitimate piece of real estates
which makes it the perfect place to
clean dirty money and lots of people
have been taking advantage of it the
latest corruption perceptions index
found that Dubai has become an active
Global Hub for money laundering where
the corrupt and other criminals can go
by luxurious property with no
restrictions end quote and many other
countries agree whenever you have an
opaque luxury real estate market with
lack regulatory control you're actually
making a choice to uh support official
corruption transnational crime and
political violence the UAE has even been
put on an anti-money laundering grade
list because they just aren't trying
hard enough to stop moneya
[Music]
launders I've been to Dubai before I had
a great time I think it's a great
getaway if you have money you're not an
American citizen and you want to save on
taxes but is Dubai My First Choice
definitely not the best way I can
describe it is like Las veg
but with much much more wealth No
gambling or alcohol and obviously less
of the old fat Americans gambling their
lives away it's got the desert Vibe but
even though it's tourist friendly you
can definitely feel like you're being
watched the entire time if you know what
I mean now one thing to keep in mind
about Dubai and this whole what they're
trying to accomplish right so they are
trying to show this image right and you
need to conform within that image so for
example Dubai labeled a very safe place
maybe not by mainstream media in the
west but it is a very safe place and so
if you do anything that is not safe like
you shouldn't come here and expect to
get in a fight or if you're trying to
bring drugs into the country like just
don't do it that is one thing Dubai is
very very big on is providing safety for
all the citizens which something I truly
appreciate so you know just don't try
and do anything stupid basically don't
steal don't try and take drugs don't
drink on the streets be respectful to
everyone and but if you're not if you're
trying to taint the image that the bi
trying to show you know you're also
going to get punished for it very
heavily and that's also why this place
is so safe is because no one wants to
end up in a jail in Dubai I don't know
what it's like but I think I've read and
I could imagine at least that is not the
most ideal standard you know if you're
in a jail and Denmark it's basically a
paid vacation you have like a TV you can
get a PlayStation you have a nice bed
and everything in Dubai I'm 100% I
guarantee you you won't get a TV and the
people there are a mixed bag you'll see
a lot of normal looking business people
but but you also come across a lot of
the complete degenerate types that you
definitely want to stay away from would
you want to raise a family there
probably not would I live there even if
I could save on taxes probably not
before the right person du buy is
Paradise and I am totally down to visit
again but regardless of all the
controversies and downsizes when it
comes to Dubai One Thing Remains clear
as long as the West keeps demonizing and
taxing the very people that create the
jobs that create the businesses that are
actually the ones that add value to
society the rich are going to keep
flooding to places like Dubai which is
just going to send the West into further
and further turmoil the only thing that
America has going for is that by law
America is one of the only two countries
where they will tax you no matter where
you live which is why you don't see many
American citizens flocking to Dubai for
taxes and what is the only other country
that does this an East African nation
called arria which I'm pretty sure most
of you don't even know where that is on
the map so yeah the US is in good
company with this law and with the West
just speed running towards higher taxes
more regulation and more laws while they
print more money while they get more and
more desperate to keep their citizens
from leaving I would not be surprised if
more and more more Western countries
soon follow suit by also taxing their
citizens abroad the last thing that I
really feel like is a big Pro and what
I've really appreciated about living in
duice the vision they have for this
country so in Europe in the US like
there's not a ton of vision for what do
we want to achieve in the next 10 20 30
40 50 years like there's not a a grand
master plan for what are we trying to
develop in this country like we have in
the UAE and Dubai especially so to give
you context like in Dubai there's
literally always something new being
built there's something new being
launched you can go into any Emar office
which is the state-owned or Emirate
owned real estate company and they will
have these like massive layouts of many
cities basically that they're trying to
build so right now they're trying to
build the I think it's the world's
biggest casino or something they're also
still in the process of building the
next world's tallest tower and there's
just always something new going on like
they have a very clear vision for what
they want to achieve
economically safety wise education wise
Health healthwise for the country which
is not something that I see being done
in Denmark and in Europe specifically
but sure in Europe and in the US and the
West in general like you do have these
different things that they're trying to
go towards but it's not as concrete as
it is in Dubai like okay in Dubai hey we
want to build x amount of skyscrapers
you know we want to provide housing for
x amount of people we want to make sure
that we are top 10 in the world in
education we want to make sure that we
recycling 100% of our water and our
water safety levels are as good as they
can possibly be or like they are to the
standard right so there's always
something happening in Du buai and
because there's not this democracy
basically it just makes the resistance
levels much lower so they can actually
get more stuff done and when you live in
a society where everyone and even like
the head hono basically the guy the
ruler of Dubai where they're very
forward thinking and they're actually
executing on stuff that also does
something to you where you get to the
buy and you actually also want to
accomplish something right cuz you are
literally in a city where people are all
about accomplishment they want to
accomplish something they want to get
better right either financially
spiritually physically mentally everyone
is in Dubai to be in a better position
when they leave than they were when they
got here that's what du buy basically is
all about so if you have money which I
know a lot of you watching this do which
I find very cool that you watch this
channel by the way you want to start
thinking about a plan B maybe you don't
move right now but you should have
something in the back of your pocket
just in case things do go down in your
country and you got to leave we'll be
going over exactly how to do that in an
upcoming video so make sure you
subscribe stay dangerous and I'll see
you in the next
[Music]
one